Uh, and gee can probably give you more, uh, details today,
but we're taking every single domain that, um, we've ever,
uh, purchased, including your guys's domains
that you have hooked up to your software or whatever.
And in the past, we had to used a service like let's, uh,
let's encrypt or whatever it's called
that would auto register, um, you know,
your SSL for you, right?
Uh, now the good news is CloudFlare has made changes on
their pro plan where we can, uh, auto register that SSL
Bad news is we're having to make all these changes
to get all of our domains over there to, uh, CloudFlare.
So like this morning, um, one
of the domains was down and then we fixed it.
And it's a matter of, we have over 700 domains, guys.
So it's a, it's a matter of us going through
and making sure that we capture each and every one.
But, uh, the link for this call, GI assume,
uh, people are probably just going to entourage.
Is that the, let me,
let me see if that's the one that's down.
And did I explain that right, G? Yeah.
Excuse me. Yeah,
so we mentioned entourage this morning to him though, right?
Can you make sure he's on that one
and just let him know that people were trying
to join the call just now and we couldn't get it to work?
Yeah, I really, okay, perfect.
Um, so yeah, let us work through that stuff there, guys.
Like, tech is always changing, man,
but the good news is, um, we have struggled with the, uh,
SSLs in the past just
because of how big of our suite is and, and everything else.
And so that takes care of that problem
and it also takes care of the, um, c name issue.
So I decided this week, I said, you know what?
I'm willing to bite the bullet.
I know there's gonna be some obstacles in the road,
but hopefully this will be like our final stop
and then we will have this SSL thing behind us
and the server issue behind us and everything else.
So, uh, that's why, uh, you might notice
that there's some notices coming out from SMTP
and everything is because of the changes
that we're making in our infrastructure
and the changes we're doing in the server
and everything, um, that is triggering those.
So we're trying to work through, uh, all that this week,
but it's not really like anything that's a deal breaker,
but some things have come from it.
Uh, we made some changes on Letterman,
I think on Sunday night.
Uh, I finally gave 'em the go to push it
and on, uh, Monday, um,
that screwed up our GC just for a minute.
So I went in there
and made sure all the newsletters sent out
that day that they were all blue.
Like we monitor, you know, each
and every newsletter we know, we wanna make sure
that every single one of 'em goes out.
And so we, uh, built the plan, we built the precaution
that if there was something that stopped
that newsletter from going out,
that there was a backup plan that would send it out.
There's a Quran job looking for every five minutes
to resend it out.
So all those things, it's kind of interesting.
They're all going into place this week, um,
which is really, really good.
So just to kind of give you guys an idea where I'm at
with things, um, like my night team
that's been working on Core Sprout and working on Min Bird
and everything, they're still working a little bit on Min
Bird, but I'm getting to the point where I'm like, man,
they keep saying what's the next priority?
I'm like, you know,
after three years, I'm gonna tell you, I'm not quite sure.
We've reached the point where we're just going back around,
just like I said, we would this way year,
and we're crossing the T's and,
and dotting the i's like you may see inside of your, um,
something that was always irritating for me
and I just couldn't get to it, was the tags.
If you open up a tag or you go into a group,
then the scroll bar was gone, right?
Well, that was fixed. Or if you went into your tag group
and you went to create new tags, it would say, you know,
you can separate tags by commas.
I'm like, forget it. Just remove that.
Just say, what's the name of your tag, right?
So we're going through and trying
to just perfect things the best we can.
And the reason why, and I'm gonna show you guys today,
I'm gonna show you some results.
We have a really, really good system, man.
We have a good system.
We might not as be as big
and intricate as something like go high level
with all their social media stuff
and all their agency stuff and all this stuff.
I don't think I ever want to be, to tell you the truth.
I think we have enough spaghetti as it is.
Um, but I'm gonna tell you right now, when it comes
to being effective, my God, we are effective.
And I found myself, I was on a, a presentation, um,
the other day and they asked me,
they were asking me about email deliverability.
Somebody mentioned, Hey, you should talk to Chad
because what he's doing with email deliverability is better
than anything I've ever seen before.
And they were talking about red light, green light.
Now I'm gonna show you guys some of the updates in both
of these platforms
because it is, just so you guys know, that when you try
to reengage, if anybody, you know,
if I go on my wall right now,
and if I say, Hey, who has a dead list?
I guarantee I can reengage at least 10
to 15% of it, right?
Everybody would freak out
because you know that when you get reengagement
going, you're lucky.
You're lucky if you reengage like three to 5% of your list.
Did you guys know this? If you do, if you do this
with typical workflows, like I've laid out, you're lucky
if you can reengage that much.
But we've been over here doing two things.
I told you, I promise you guys
doesn't gonna gimme an update.
So, can you guys see my screen right now?
Let me know if you guys can see my screen.
Uh, where's the chat? Okay, go.
So, uh, this is what we've been talking about.
Um, I'm gonna start with this one right here.
Uh, I think we're pretty close to getting this done.
So you can see that we went through
and we created this free membership
and we've been using it to engage.
So 2%, 1%, 2%,
but look, this is just two hours ago, three hours,
four hours ago, seven days ago, 4%, 3%,
3, 3, 3, 3, 5, 8, 5, 7, 9, 10, 7, 9, 6, 8, 17, 3, 4, 5, 2,
11%, 14%, a hundred percent, 12%, a hundred percent, 7%,
a hundred percent, 1%, 2%.
Uh, don't worry about this one. Uh, 3%, 1%.
And then you can see that it's, uh, we haven't, we have not,
it actually started, it stopped here.
Sorry, I should have stopped here.
So we started a little over two weeks ago.
That's what we got. Now the thing is, we're not done there
because what's gonna happen is you guys
wanna pay attention to this.
If you've ever had a list before,
pay attention to what I'm telling you.
Once it gets all the way to the top
and we have this all filled in,
then we're gonna come back over here to our reminder.
Uh, and we haven't done this one yet,
so lemme go down to one that he has done.
We're gonna go back to our reminder, and I'm gonna go ahead
and put in a new subject line, something
that's more captivating,
and we'll keep everything else the same.
And then we're gonna go through and,
and we're gonna do it again.
We're gonna hit that reminder, hit that reminder, hit
that reminder, hit that reminder, hit that reminder,
and this number is going to keep growing and growing
and growing and growing and growing.
Now, you might notice something.
Let me see if I can find a difference. Three 30, okay?
There's a little bit of a difference here.
Uh, a little bit of a difference here, a little bit here,
here, hold on, let me go up.
Uh, where is the difference at g I'm not seeing
4 6 9 4 58 4 19.
Okay, so let me come over here
and let's look at this other one.
So that was the one company,
but this one's engaged a lot better.
So 2%, 2%, 4%, 2%, 2%,
3, 4, 3, 4, 9, 9, 7, 9, 6, 4, 5, 4, 4, 8, 11, 7, 13, 17, 10, 12.
Um, yeah, I don't know
how this 113, but 83%.
82%. 81%. And that's where it stops, right?
But see how there's a little bit of a difference here.
We went and scrubbed, um, these lists,
but what's happening is, uh, when we go
and send out our reminders, it's getting,
it's coming back as a hard bounce.
And so when it's coming back as a hard bounce,
we wanna remove it.
And that's why you have, like, this one had 541
that we cleaned up, and the first time we went
and sent it, it came back
and it said, Hey, uh, three of 'em, 38, 39, 44, 1 3
of 'em are hard bounces.
And so truthfully, this 7% is based off
of this number, not that number.
Does that make sense to you guys? So what we did,
and it's been pretty crazy, is we have built out horse route
to be the most incredible, uh, re-engagement system ever.
And it is never been easier just to come in here
and re-engage a massive list.
Now, this was this company, but if we look at this one,
this one's been a little bit harder to reengage.
But if I come down here, and if I look at this, let's see,
0%, 2%, 1%, 2%, 4%,
3, 3, 3, 3, 3, 5, 8, uh,
5, 7, 9, 10, 7, 9, 6, 8, 7, 7, 3, 4, 5, 2, 11, 14,
a hundred percent, 12%, and a hundred percent.
Okay? So is this all kind
of starting to make sense right now?
And we can just come in here
and just keep clicking on this little airplane,
but once we get this all filled,
so there's gonna be a one all the way down,
then we're gonna go change the subject line,
and then we're gonna hit it again.
And then we're gonna have all twos all the way down,
and then it'll be about a two week stretch,
and then we'll hit it again.
And there'll be three. And we'll do this
for like the next three months.
And I'm pretty sure I can get this to a 30% re-engagement.
Is, is that making sense to everybody?
Yeah. So this, this, this, this is here,
this is pretty phenomenal guys.
It's never ever been done this way, ever.
Uh, I got Ray Lane working on his,
I got Karthik working on his,
but let me show you, um, what is happening because of this.
So if I come over here, you see they got all kinds
of stuff happening there, everything's good.
But let's come over here, the contacts.
And if I look at the contacts, you're gonna see
that now we have gone in this, not this account.
Hold on, let me get in the right account.
I'm, I'm logged into so many different things here, guys.
Uh, let me, let me go back into there
and let me try to click here.
Okay, there we go. So if I come over here to contacts,
uh, and let me make sure
that I'm not in my account right now.
Okay? So if we come over here to contacts, yeah,
this is his account, okay?
We have 3,626 openers
and 1093 clickers.
Now, to give you an idea what that means, guys,
I was beating out, I was winning all the promotions.
Every single thing I did last year,
I promoted, I was number one.
I beat up the biggest guys in the business, took all stages
of prizes, took everything.
I did that based off of 400 clickers.
See this, he is now at 1093
clickers, 3,626 openers.
Uh, 1.78% is inactive right now.
Uh, passive is 9.1% and then most of 'em are in the new.
Now, why is there 93,000 in the new?
Because when you import the contacts
into Core Sprout, it creates a contact record inside a gc.
Does that make sense?
Are y'all starting to follow? So if I come back over here
to answer Josh's question, what happens, Josh, is
you could do this, actually, you create a free membership.
And then what happens is, like, I'm having
to reengage like 500,000 people.
So we're starting out 500 chunks
because he has a brand new SMTP account, right?
So we take all these people, we break them into 500 chunks,
and then what happens is when we click this airplane here,
it sends out a reminder email to everybody.
So if I come in here, this is a reminder email,
and it basically says, Hey, reminder log into here and here,
and then here's the email.
Just wanna shoot you a quick message
to make sure you receive this.
Uh, we show you haven't logged in yet,
here's your access details.
So please take a minute to log in.
Uh, and then once we've seen you log in,
we'll stop sending this reminder.
So every single time we click on this airplane over here,
it's gonna mail everybody that has not logged in.
So this isn't what you're seeing here, guys.
This isn't just clickers.
These are people that have logged
into the actual course sprout.
Does that make sense? Now?
So if you've got a list of a thousand people, of 500 people
or whatever else, you could do this very easily
and it's gonna give you your start.
And it's the very best re-engagement I've ever seen.
Now, we went out there
and we tried to do something, it didn't go exactly
as planned, but it's okay.
But I wanna show you the difference.
'cause I think this is one of the biggest scams in our
business, and I'm getting ready
to blow the whistle on the scam, honestly.
Um, so if I come over here
to domain reporting,
and, uh, you're gonna see
that this is the mail gun, okay?
Harmonic. So mail gun is getting, um,
yes, hold on a second.
So these are mail gun stats that we started out with,
and then I don't know what happened to his mail gun account,
but right now we have, um, SMTP, right?
So I'm gonna go ahead and open this up
and I'm gonna show you, this is the
trend of what's happening.
I'm gonna show you the broadcast.
So here's a, here's a broadcast we sent.
So we sent it to 3,533 people.
It accepted 3,117, it delivered to 2,883.
Now, I don't know why it only did 92%,
but whatever, that's where we're starting now.
We did have huge unsubscribes, but that's expected.
Um, but if I come over here,
and, uh, this was the email,
it was a brand new type of email.
I was trying to teach, uh, the staff how to do this, right?
Um, and it was just a, it was just a value email.
And then, uh,
it went into ps make sure you purchase this product, right?
And I think we got like four sales on the product.
So it did like $200 or something. Nothing special.
But what I'm trying to show you is we sent
2,883 emails,
had a 39% open rate
and had 191 clicks, okay?
Huge drops. That's expected when we're starting out, right?
But now I'm gonna compare it to what we were doing.
Lemme see if I can get in here for you.
Uh, and I want you guys to see the difference.
And this is why I'm telling you, this
to me is the biggest scam in the business.
It is such a scam. It's not even funny.
And I never realized what a scam it was
until I really started working for this company.
So look at this here. This one was sent a day ago.
We sent it to
34,964 people.
And look at this guys. We got 8,000 opens
and 143 clicks.
How many of you just had a huge light bulb moment?
We sent this to 34,000 people.
We sent this to 35,000 people.
8,000 opens, 119 clicks.
We we sent this to 35,000 people.
Uh, 8,000 opens again
and 154 clicks, right?
Are you guys seeing this right now?
So wait a minute, Chad, you're telling me
that you mailed 34,000 people over here
and over here in gc, you only mailed 2,883
and you got higher clicks.
How many of you just connected the dots?
So wait a minute, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on a second. Hold on a second.
I've been, I've been thinking this through too.
I've been really starting to understand my own software.
I didn't really get it till I got it.
So could any autoresponder go do this?
Guys, do you think that we're so freaking special with
what we've done that it's rocket science?
What we figured out, do you guys truly believe
that ActiveCampaign could do the same thing?
That MailChimp could do the same thing,
that AWeber could do the same thing?
Do you guys think that the minute somebody opens,
they could turn it green the minute somebody hasn't opened
for 30 days, they could turn it red And if somebody hasn't,
uh, opened after that for 45 days, they turn it black.
Do you guys think another autoresponder could do that?
Because I'm telling you right now, they could.
So the question becomes why don't they,
why don't they give you the ability
to have the same exact clicks if you only
are mailing this many people?
Doesn't that make sense for you guys?
It makes total sense, doesn't it? Yes or no?
This model makes sense for you guys. Think about it.
You can mail what, 50,000 people right now for what?
25 bucks a month, but for them it doesn't make sense.
You wanna know why? Because they are charging you
not based on what we sent,
but they are charging you based on the number
of contacts.
And that's what I'm telling you right now.
They are charging us $1,500 a month based off
of 40,000 contacts.
And I'm gonna let this thing go. Okay?
So based off of 40,000 contacts
that charging $1,500 a month,
and you guys can pay $25 a month
and have the kind of results that I'm seeing here,
on a scale of one outta 10,
how many of you're starting to understand this?
Now, how many of you're starting
to get this size?
Doesn't matter. Size doesn't matter.
And what's gonna happen is this system here, guys, is going
to really help you understand that.
Now, uh, I don't wanna let the cattle bag it,
but, um, Connie's not a client, a really, really, really,
really, really big client, um,
that has, uh, been getting his haircut with her for a while,
and he's been talking to her
and he made the statement to her the other day.
He goes, well, I went back to my boss
and I told him that my hairstylist has more knowledge about,
uh, email, email deliverability than, uh,
anybody else in our organization, right?
So I told her, I'm like, well, you should offer
to help 'em, you should.
You, you would probably end up doing all the email
for everybody in the organization.
Why? Well, because look at our abilities to,
to reengage guys, look at
what we can do now with Course Sprout.
I'm not saying that's gonna be a fit for everybody,
but my God, it's incredible, right?
But now how many of you understand the value
of these boxes right here?
And this is before we get into Hot listing
and everything else, just,
just understanding what's happening here.
This should start to make a lot of sense to you.
Like a lot of sense to you, right?
So pay your $25 a month with SMTP or whatever
and compare that to $1,500 a month
that you would be paying with Active Campaign
or Entreport or Get Response or any of 'em.
And guess what? You guys are one of the few people that
actually understand this, right?
If I, if I talk
to go high level people, you know what they tell me?
Oh, no, email hasn't changed,
it's just we use their SMTP to do it.
So it's all the same.
They're all still mailing all their active contacts.
And if they don't wanna do it that way, I was talking
to somebody the other day, they have
to build all this automation
and everything, uh, to be able to tell who's active, who's,
guys, you have it happening right here
before your eyes is, is everybody starting to see us now?
And have you guys been seeing your
dashboard light up like this?
Have you guys been seeing this?
And have you been paying attention
to what's showing over here in your details now
with your broadcast, with your workflows?
If you got it with your pipelines, if you got it.
Like, have you guys been paying attention to all that?
It's pretty extraordinary. I'm pretty proud of this system.
And now, like I said, like one
of the most annoying things was the tags where if you went
and if you edited a tag
or whatever, the scroll bar, uh, would not come back, right?
Well, now it's coming back, right?
So you can go into the groups and everything
that's been annoying for like two years now, right?
So we got that all fixed.
But I don't want you to think
that Nick Nikki co is something special or something
because I'm gonna show you how many of you're curious
what happens with the, uh, hustle 2.0.
Is there anybody who would like to see that?
Is there anybody who would like to see what happened there?
Okay, so just a recap.
Came over here, created the Hustle
2.0, by the way, is it pretty good?
You guys know for a fact that I shot that in a day, right?
I shot it in in one single day.
So, uh, I don't know if I can do that yet.
So let me, let me go through
and let me, let me do it this way.
I'll, I'll do it the old school way until G gets
that link fixed for me.
Uh, let's come through here for you guys. Okay?
So, um, okay,
I gotta, I gotta update.
I changed this to where you guys have to, uh, you have
to update your, your picture, right?
Okay, so there we go.
I can see the potential in the system you're teaching.
Can someone please contact me at no point? Let's see.
This link is bad. Okay, cool.
So let's come down here and let's look at this.
Okay, so, so far 246 comments. I gotta re-shoot that video.
It was too dark that day, but look at it, guys.
We're, we're off to the races. Would you guys agree?
Would you agree that we are off
to the races with this course?
Yes or no? And by the way,
this is the reason why I'm making everybody load their
picture now, because look how incredible that looks, right?
Look how incredible that looks.
So it looks like Mark Jovin has gone all the way through.
I forgot to load the final badge here.
I still need to do that, but I still got time to do that.
But see how great this looks guys?
Okay, so when somebody new comes in here,
I, I don't have to preach that.
I think you guys know, I think you know how that works.
And then I came up here and I put some links up there.
We're getting sales from up there too, right?
Okay, so great.
But the main point was to have a really,
really attention getting hook that I could use
to reengage the list.
Okay? So now let me tell you what happened. Alright?
So I'm gonna click here
and I'm gonna go to the pricing options
and you're gonna see, so we're gonna go over here
to Chad's vault.
This is what I use to reengage
and let's start at the bottom.
Okay? So this one we just did recently.
So 0, 0, 0, 1%, 1%, 0%, 1%,
2%, 2%, 1%, 12%.
Look at the numbers here guys.
12%, 11%, 14%, 7%, 0%,
0%, 1%, 7% 0, 0 2, 7, 5.
And then, uh,
that was the actual people actually signing up.
Okay? So if we look at this right now,
you can't count these two.
Okay? This is how I want you guys to see this
and understand this is only our first time through, okay?
Add 33 plus eight plus one, plus 22 plus seven,
plus two plus two plus 36 plus 69, plus 56,
plus 62 plus seven, plus 12, plus 12 plus four,
plus two plus five plus six, plus one plus one.
And all we did was come over here and click this airplane
and we're gonna do it for the next three months.
But what's gonna happen is we're getting ready to get out
of my birthday month.
And so then, uh, let me come up here where I can show you
where we recently did it.
Then um, this here is gonna change
where it says today is my
50th birthday, blah, blah, blah, blah.
I'm gonna change the subject now, okay?
And I'm gonna take out the birthday thing
and I'm just gonna keep hitting everybody till I get that
to 25, 30% re-engagement.
How many of you're understanding this?
Very, very successful. So what were the results?
Well, let's come over here and let's open this up.
Look how fast this stuff comes in now, right?
Lemme go to mine.
Let how fast this stuff comes in, guys,
look at this, look at this.
Oh, I wanna talk to you about this too. Okay?
So, um, if we come over here,
if we look at our contacts, what do we got?
I went from 3000 openers
to 7,000 openers.
I went from about 600 clickers to
1300 clickers.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
How many of you're starting to see this?
This is the very best way.
And I know marketers will rip me off
or whatever else, but we really did.
We were the ones that figured this out.
This is the very best way to reengage your list.
Does that give you guys some ideas?
So now remember what I taught you guys,
I think last week or the week before?
I can't remember. I said, okay, now the goal is
how do we keep 'em in the green?
How do we keep 'em in the green?
Uh, how many of you received my email yesterday?
Let's come over here, let's look at this.
Let's come over here and let's look at it.
Did anybody receive my email yesterday?
Let's see. Okay,
did you guys find it fascinating?
I was talking to Jim Phillips about doing this.
I was waiting for his results.
I don't know if, I don't know if he ever did it or not,
but I just said, screw it yesterday.
I'm like, I need to understand, I need to understand what
to do to keep everybody in the green.
So here was the email. I think I can
click this here and show you.
Okay? This was the email right here
and we definitely had a,
a spelling error there, but that's okay.
Punctuation. I'm deciding
what we focus on building this next year
and I wanna make sure it's actually useful to you.
So guys, all of these are links.
Now, what do you think is behind one of these links?
What do you think is behind one of these links? A tag.
A tag. Now let's look at how this did.
So I told him, send it to the green.
Send it to the green, send it to the green
and reengage what you can.
So we sent it to the green, which was like, what,
7,000 or something like that.
I said, make sure you reengage some of the red. Okay?
So that's why it's 9,966. It accepted 9,787.
It delivered 9,000 723 99 0.35% delivery rate.
I'm happy with that. Opens with 38%.
We had 549 clicks.
Guys, dude, pay attention
to what I'm showing you.
Look how many clicks I've been getting when I mailed a
green look.
243. This is green.
Uh, 111, this is green. No, that's not green.
Let's come down here to where we got more green. Okay?
Like this one here, this is green, right?
335 clicks, right? 242 clicks.
See this? This is the most clicks I have had
in a very long time.
I was talking to Karthik Gram yesterday who's very,
very active in the launch world and everything.
I said, dude, how many clicks do you average in your email?
He said, about 300. The reengagement that I'm doing guys
gave me a 14.76% click through rate
on this many people.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
On a scale of one outta 10,
is everybody understanding what you're seeing?
So I was talking to Connie all morning, I'm like,
we gotta figure something out.
Our re-engagement is top notch.
We have figured out something
that nobody else has figured out.
Like when I'm done re-engaging guys,
I'm gonna have 25, 2500 active clickers.
Like I said, when I was on top of my game,
I had 400 active clickers.
Now I'm gonna have 2,500 active clickers.
I'm gonna have at least 150 people on the calls. Great.
We're in a good position. The question is,
what do we start mailing?
'cause mail is not my strength. So guess what?
We took that email yesterday
and see this group over here that it says interest survey.
I'm gonna go ahead and open this up. And what do you see?
77 people told me, affiliate marketing,
96 people told me AI
and automations 25 said, becoming an influencer.
80 people said, creating a media company.
62 said dominating local business 170 said,
I'm interested in all and 30 said
our software and strategies.
Now, did that tell me something?
Yes or no? Did that tell me something guys?
We'll look at this here in a minute, William.
It's pretty extraordinary, isn't it?
How many of you clicked on those links in
that email yesterday?
Is that not the easiest survey you've ever taken?
I now, if I had gone
and done quiz form, could I have got just as many results?
Yeah, I probably could have.
I wasn't really feeling well yesterday.
I was feeling lazy and I
just wanted to do something different.
So I just went through that email together.
This is what I mapped out for you, Jim. Do you remember?
It was really, really simple.
Nothing complicated.
So Jim was gonna send out an email for, uh,
his business owners or for his community
or whatever, saying, uh, you know,
are you in Northport or are you here?
Or, I can't remember what it was, but same idea.
And he would've just created a tag for each one of them
and then put the tag in the email, right?
Um, so overall this was a really,
really good response, right?
So it is very encouraging to see,
here's the other thing I wanna point out.
Okay? These, when when we come over here
and we look, when we look at,
uh, lemme get back in there.
When we look at the results,
I want you to understand something else.
Okay? Let's go back and let's look at it again.
So 553 clicks.
Guys, do you understand that that is comparing that
to something that took place five days ago, something
that took place, uh, what, 10 days ago?
It's at 553 clicks in less than 24 hours.
Do you know what that means? It's going
to be at like 700 clicks.
Seven, 800 clicks,
and that's the most that I have had
in probably two or three years.
So what I'm teaching you with your existing audience,
with the emails that you have,
please pay very close attention to it.
Because this system, uh, is a re-engagement system.
Course Sprout is the very best re-engagement I've ever seen.
The easiest re-engagement,
and by the way, it's a transaction email.
So SMTP loves it.
They love it 'cause you're just sending somebody an email
that says, Hey, just wanna make sure you got access.
We're trying to deliver, we're trying to deliver a product.
We're not even selling anything, right?
We're just trying to deliver a product.
And then when they click, they go to the green.
Now, how many of you can see this working?
A hundred percent, without a doubt.
Type in the chat, let me
know who is seeing this work.
A hundred percent without a doubt.
You, you guys are seeing this isn't, it is not just theory,
it's everything that we've been talking about Email,
about DNS, about reengagement, about red light, green light.
And now how many of you can understand why, uh, I wanted
to get Josh off of a Weber because I knew it was a scam.
How many of you're starting to see this now?
And what's so phenomenal is that if I wanted to,
so let's say this, I can now do this.
And this was not the purpose. I was really just trying
to understand what are people interested in.
But if I wanted to go out there
and if I wanted to promote some AI product
or something else, do you guys understand
that I could just go and and target this tag right here
and I'm gonna get the highest opens and the highest clicks
because these 96 people told me they want ai
and these people are still interested in affiliate marketing
and these people are definitely interested in a newsletter.
Is this making sense to you guys? Now, that was horrible.
That's a horrible way, um, to
do re to to do, uh, segmentation.
Okay? This wasn't about segmentation guys.
This was just about me putting out a survey to see
what are people interested in.
But if I come over here to this one that says, interested,
this is how you do, this is
how you bank your tag.
This is your true segmentation, right?
Putting out those little teaser videos.
And when people click the link to open those videos,
you tag them as interested.
This is your true segmentation. Okay?
So you guys are gonna start hearing a lot of people.
Um, look, this is not,
let me come off camera when I say this, okay?
Uh, this is not a shiny object anymore.
See, all they had for the longest time was email.
And so you guys heard a lot about
email back in the day, right?
The money's in the list.
You gotta build a list, blah, blah, blah, blah.
How many of you ever heard that before? Anybody? Anybody?
My partners were doing it.
You know, Amy Porterfield,
like everybody was doing it right?
Email, email, email, email.
Are you hearing about email today?
Do we hear anything else about email today? Anything at all?
No. Email's dead, isn't it?
How many of you, now that you've seen that, how many
of you think that email's dead?
Who thinks email is dead? Folks?
Email is not dead. Email is not dead.
They're just on to the next shiny object, which is ai.
That's it. They,
they don't believe in anything that they're teaching you.
It's just a shiny object that keeps their bills paid.
That's all it is. It's just hype. It's just hype.
That's all. It's okay.
So, uh, yeah, I I I want,
I want you guys doing this, okay?
I a hundred percent want you guys doing this.
Now, Jim Phillips sent me an email today.
I wanna look at this email. I, I, I was trying to read it,
uh, Jim, in the car,
you don't mind if I open up on the call, do you?
Is that okay? Can you unmute yourself by the way
and tell me, set this up for me.
I had it open. I was, I was trying to read it.
Hey Tim, Let me,
let me open this. You don't mind, do you?
No, never do. Okay, let's, no, I,
but I do wanna say one thing before you start.
I hope so. Um, that email is going
to people who have already, uh, now I'm going back
to last August of July,
who have already identified themselves as business owners
through quiz former.
However, because my original quiz former way back then
had some errors in it.
A lot of those people who signed up as business owners said,
I'm not a business owner,
but you keep asking me these dumb questions.
But the good news is all
of those people, I have their phone number.
So my goal right now with that email is to
retag those people as true business owners
and, uh, find out if they're still hot.
'cause we're talking about six months later
and I haven't had time to reach out to 'em,
or I reached out to one here or there,
and I want to get into an organized advertising campaign.
So I wrote that email with an idea towards sending it out
to the 50 or 60 people who have identified themselves
as business owners through Core Sprout.
Make sure they still are,
make sure I've still got their phone number
and reach out to 'em through an email.
And if they hit my new tag,
then I'm gonna pick 'em up with a phone call.
That's a lot. All right, well,
let's start with baby steps.
Can we start with baby steps? Sure.
So here is the email.
I couldn't log into my email from my computer guys,
so I just forwarded it to myself,
but this is the one that Jim sent me this morning.
And so,
uh, let me see something.
Was that a test you sent me
That was a sample of an email that I've written
and I have locked and loaded ready to go?
Okay, so that was not actually sent from gc, right?
Because it would replace my name?
No, no, no, no. I cut and past it
and put it into my, you know, my Gmail. Got it.
Because I'm like, why, why didn't it replace
with my name when I looked at, but, okay, that makes sense.
All right, so it'll replace the merge field.
Uh, Dave, tune in here. Make sure you check, check that out.
Right. I'm the publisher behind Northport Matters, along
with our sister sites in Venice and Port Charlotte.
If we haven't met yet, here's what we need to know.
Here's what you need to know. We live here, we work here.
I'm not some out of town media guy driving
through the area periodically
to sell you overpriced ad space.
We built these sites with one simple goal
to give local businesses like yours, a powerful,
affordable way to stay visible in front of local people.
And guess what is working?
Thousands upon thousands of Northport residents.
Check out Northport Matters every week to find local deals,
events, businesses, what's going on around town.
For instance, last month our Facebook page received over
380,000 views, uh,
which when visited displayed a custom banner
that could be yours affordably.
This isn't a spraying prey billboard.
This is a targeted, trackable bill for small business owners
who want more customers without burning cash.
Okay, so Jim, tell me what you're trying to offer them.
What do you want them to do?
Sorry, I unmuted myself again.
'cause Pam was, uh, filing her nails.
Um, I, I want them to retag themselves as warm leads,
uh, as hot leads so that I can then turn around
and reach out to them by phone.
Okay? So if you look at the links, it'll take them
to a hot tag
and that hot tag will pick up their information from
their original tag.
And once I know that they've reengaged
or whatever you wanna call it, reinterested themselves,
then I'll pick up the phone
and give 'em a phone call from that hot tag.
I want to take that hot tag and dump it into that.
Um, uh, what do you call it? Not the playlist. The, uh,
Pipeline. Yeah,
the pipeline. I want to get my pipeline going.
The whole goal is to get my pipeline going.
Okay. Got it. So, uh,
why it works and why it'll work for you.
Hyper local reach, we focus on Northport,
multi-channel exposure, web, email, social,
portable packages, no bloated agency built in trust.
People know our brand by extension.
We run the entire thing through our corporate platform,
which gives you small business, like your simple fast way
to get no visibility.
You got two options.
Keep relying on what you're doing now and business picks up.
Number two, get in front of thousands.
Locals already paying attention
to what's on Northport Matters Fire you.
I take option two, but hey, I'm biased.
I've seen the numbers. Next step, just reply this email
and say, uh, send me the details date.
Oh, personally follow up,
or Jim Phillips, our poster will,
there will be no sales team, no scripts, no pressure at all,
just me showing you exactly
what you can do for your business.
We could drop by our quick 20 minute zoom call.
We'll also do the trick. Looking forward
to helping your business stand out in the neighborhood.
Um,
Alright, Lemme check in with the group thoughts.
What do you guys think?
Uh oh, what are your Thoughts?
Anybody take out the A lines and I'm good.
Maybe shorter. What else?
Possibly too much sounds honest and real.
I think it's too long. Okay, uh, Jim, so
tell me again what you're hoping to achieve.
You wanna verify they're a business owner?
Double check that they're a business owner,
that I've got their phone number
and that they end up in my pipeline.
So I can take those 50
or 60 original business owners, turn 'em into 35
or 40 that are still hot,
and start working my pipeline to con to convert them.
So I really want to take 'em out of a tag
that says Northport Business owners.
And I want to take them into a tag that says
NPM Biz leads interested.
And from there I'll go and attack 'em.
So here's the thing. You broke a lot of rules,
Okay? 'cause
You are sending them here and here
and here and here,
and then you're telling them to do something here.
You're even like, you got two choices, right?
So that they're really gonna pay attention to.
And you got here, but then you got another call to action
that says, just reply to this email,
Those links. And then you got
Your, and then you got all your footer links here.
So you're gonna have a problem with spam to start with.
But second of all, I would be really confused if I was
a business owner, wouldn't you?
All of those links go to, um, like the,
in the very first line that the, where it says Venice,
that goes to, um,
because I'm sending it out to Northport,
they might also be interested in Venice.
So that Venice tag goes to Venice Biz leads interested,
in other words, another hot tag, but for Venice.
So it'll put 'em into a different tag
and I'll know how to follow up with 'em.
They're not interested in Northport,
they're interested in Venice, but they are interested,
and I can put them into my Venice pipeline.
That tag goes into my Venice pipeline
and I can start working them through the pipeline.
Same thing with this one that says Port Charlotte.
All of these links go to hotlink tags.
One of three hotlink tags.
I don't think you're gonna like me today.
Let's play with this.
You know, the content doesn't
really make any difference.
The words you write, the whole idea is to get it from the
North port business leads into the North port biz leads
interested hot tag
and into the pipeline, no matter what the content says.
I wrote that.
Okay, I'm, I'm gonna tell you. So here's the thing.
I got something over here that I've done,
but I wanna, um, clearly, uh, you,
you obviously use Chad GPT to do this,
right? Uh,
Yes. Partly yes.
Gonna kiss my butt and tell me what I want to know, right?
No, actually, it's the first time I've seen it.
Say you're off as a verification email.
This is way too sales heavy, not tight enough with the goal.
You stated big picture. This reads like a full ad pitch.
That's what I'm gonna tell you, Jim. You're selling.
And the goal is not to make the sale right now,
not a business owner verification check.
If your real goal is confirm this person actually owns
or operates a business in Northport,
then this email's doing five times
necessary and it creates friction.
A non-owner could easily ignore it, feel sold,
assume it's spam, miss the actual ask entirely.
What's good about it. Let's be fair.
Local credibility angle. We live here, we work here.
Hyper local framing, northport only.
Clear authority, social proof, simple. CTA.
This is not a bad sales email,
it's just the wrong email for the state of gold.
And this is what I was trying to tell you too.
Well, it's not working for verification.
There is no explicit verification.
Ask nowhere to say, are you the owner?
Do you still operate this business?
Is is this business located in Northport?
So your hoping intent equals verification, which is weak.
It attracts curiosity.
Clicks, not owners, non-owners, marketers,
tire kickers could reply to just pricing.
Learn more, check it out.
I don't know about that part, but way I didn't tell it
that we are gonna try to only send it
to people we think are business owners, right?
Way too long for a trust test verification.
Email should feel low pressure, quick,
almost administrative.
Easy answer in five seconds.
This feels like I'm about to be sold something.
What I changed without re rewriting the whole thing.
If the verification is first test is if the goal is
verification first, sale second,
you need one clear fork in the road.
And that's yes owner, no, not owner,
wrong contact right now.
There's no fork. Minimum fixes keep most of the email.
If you'd want to manually adjust this exact email,
I'd recommend add a verification line
at the top before the pitch.
Quick check first, are you the owner
or manager of a business in Northport?
This reframes everything.
Add a binary reply, CTA at the bottom instead.
Send me the details, Dave. Yes, I own a business.
No, not the right person. Moved a pitch up,
my honest verdict as a sales email,
7.5 outta 10 as a verification.
Email three outta 10 as a list cleaning tool. Two outta 10.
You're leaving a ton of signal on the table
by not explicitly asking the one thing you care about.
Okay? So are you guys curious to see
what I just wrote just from knowing what his goal is?
And it's not perfect, it was fast.
I just open up, uh, you know, notepad over here,
understanding that he doesn't have a
relationship with these people yet.
So they're not gonna give him a lot of time.
Are you guys curious? And then
we'll plug it in and we'll see.
And then Jim's free to do what he wants to do.
He has proven me wrong a hundred times.
He might be absolutely correct on this. I don't know.
Um, but this is what I did.
Hey, Chuck, Dave from Northport Matters.
We run the biggest publication in the community.
You do own a business in the area, right?
I'd love to connect.
What are your thoughts when you read that, Jim?
It's perfect because you're just gonna No,
you're just gonna throw that one tag right
there when they say yes.
But, um, I wanted to write one email
that would serve three different cities. Okay?
Because so change, so change the,
oh, I see what you're saying.
Just have tags to the other two.
I'm gonna send it to Northport.
Uh, and then I'll turn around and send the same email
and just change a couple of words. I'll
Send it to, okay, you just change the name, right?
Just change this Yep. And change that. Yep.
Yep. So you're gonna get,
you're gonna get replies though.
Yeah. And I like your idea of having the one that you sent
this morning with those seven links in it.
I thought that was great. I I, I realized
that I probably should just do something like that.
Uh, are you interested in advertising in Venice?
Are you interested in advertising in Northport?
Are you interested in advertising? In in,
Yeah, maybe. I mean, there's less, there's
not a lot of obstacle to it.
It's really fast for people.
They can do it from their phone, right?
Obviously our software works well for that.
Um, so let's, let's see what, um, now
how did I arrive at this as fast as I did?
Well, because I asked Jim, I was trying to really understand
what is his goal.
And when he said, I'm just trying to verify
that they're a business owner, I'm like, okay, so
what do we need to ask somebody?
And Chad, GPT pretty much told you that.
Look, if you wanna know that, then uh,
you need to ask him that.
And that's what was kind of missing, right?
So let's see how close we are.
Obviously it should find something wrong with it.
Um, but let me see.
And, and by the way, this is something
that everybody could do to,
and it's funny that this is happening right now.
I'm gonna tell you why. It's funny because, uh,
I was dealing with some stuff this morning
with the other company and um, I was feeling kind of down
and I went in there and I was talking to Connie
and she's like, she's like, we need
to mail our business owners.
And I was like, yeah, we need to do that, right?
And so it's interesting that we're doing this right now,
all kind of in the plan, right?
Okay, so let's see what it says.
And like I said, that was just my instincts talking guys.
So you're very close. The intent is right.
It just needs to sound more human, less awkward
and more credible without staying ultra short.
All right? So let's see. Let's see how much
of it has changed except to put in stupid dashes, right?
Hey Chuck, quick check.
Are you the owner or operator
of a business here in Northport?
I'm Dave. And the report matters.
Local publication focus are entirely on this community.
If this is you, I'd love to connect.
Yeah, that's, this is good too.
If this is you, do you know who the person is, Jim?
Yes. Okay, perfect. So that's a nice line.
If this is you, I'd love to connect, right? Mm-hmm.
So if you do something like this, I think the, yeah,
I think this is better positioning.
I just think you gotta be careful with it
so they don't feel like they're about to get served
or something, right?
When you say, are you the owner, right?
Instead of in, instead of doing it like that, hey, just, uh,
you could say, I believe you're the operator or something.
I would be less direct.
But either way, I think any of this will work.
Does that make it easier for you?
Yeah, I think that's a great idea.
The, uh, you know, the thing is they're already subscribers
or they wouldn't be business.
Uh, they wouldn't be already in there as business owners.
So they're getting my newsletter,
so they're getting my articles.
They're probably following 'em on Facebook.
So I don't really need to reintroduce myself so much.
I need to tell 'em what I can do for 'em.
So that's why I wrote out that whole long email. Mm-hmm.
Because they're not gonna recognize me as a stranger.
They're gonna recognize the name. But, um, well
If that's the case, then put your logo at the top of it.
Yep. Right? Drag
Your drag northport matters in and put it at the top.
Yep. Yep.
Right? And then put your picture at the
bottom or whoever's picture.
And the whole goal of all of this is
to start to use the pipeline.
'cause the pipeline wasn't there when these people all
signed up last July, August, September. So yeah,
The pipeline's pretty amazing.
And uh, what I was telling Jim, uh, guys, our main focus,
and I think I told you guys this is to me,
and I'm old school, I told you the story about when I came
out of Mastermind, how to go hire a sales team
and you know, spent like $8,000 on solo ads
or something, was all excited,
thought I was gonna make a million dollars, you know,
that week, whatever, selling that program.
And then the guy came back
after I paid $5,000 to hire the sales team
and came back, said all the leads were garbage.
And I said, all of them. He goes, all of them.
I said, well, how do you know that? He
goes, 'cause my girl went through.
I said, well, what does your girl do?
Well, she goes through and, and looks at the question
and then determines, you know, if they're qualified or not.
I said, and how are they qualified?
Well, based on how they answer, based on how they answer,
they either go in stack A or stack B
and stack A is qualified, stack B is not qualified.
And all of your people went into stack B not qualified.
I was like, okay, fine. So I went
and built a tool called survey, S-U-R-V-A-Y.
And what survey did was it was the first time that we took
a jot form application.
And based on how you answered, you either went into pile A
or pile B and I fired the sales team.
I fired that guy. I said, you guys go pound send.
And then I just had a software
that did the qualifications for you.
And then we built a, an appointment system
into it afterwards.
And you know, you guys know the story,
but that's kind of how that worked.
Well, it's still, I'm still doing the same thing.
So how I've always understood a pipeline was
that when you filled out a, uh, an application, like if,
if you, um, uh,
filled out this application here, okay, then, uh,
and yeah, this is quiz forma by the way, uh, based on
how you answer, okay?
Uh, based on how you answer is if you're qualified
or disqualified, right?
Did you know you could make your quizzes look this good?
Jim,
Jim Phillips. I think you're muted buddy.
Sorry, I muted myself. Yes, I've done that.
The only thing that I couldn't do was
put my logo at the top.
I did on a couple, but on a couple others I
couldn't. So I'm not sure why.
Might wanna refresh it 'cause we
made it bigger and everything else.
Um, but this is,
it looks even better on the phone, honestly, guys.
But here's the thing, right?
This is, this is what we've done.
And I want to confuse you guys.
If you come over here to tags, you got standard,
qualified and disqualified, right?
So that's based on how they answer. Okay?
Now see this section down here, it says add the pipeline.
This is where you choose your pipeline.
This is where you choose the status.
This is where you choose the, the stage.
This is where you can assign an opportunity or a deal.
And then if you had staff,
you could go ahead and assign a staff.
Okay? So when somebody fills out that quiz, um,
they automatically drop into your pipeline.
And this is what I'm gonna try to do
with you guys on the business owners, right?
So if I go back into Nick's pipeline,
you have qualified and you have disqualified.
So these leads are just falling in
based off of how they took the quiz.
And what we can do that's really cool
is see this thing over here that says pipeline list view.
You're able to go through here and look at a list view,
and you can just come over here
and, and this is what they do.
They come in here and they look at the,
they look at the quiz answers over here, uh,
and then they'll simply come over here and click here
and they'll claim the lead,
and then they'll follow up with the lead, right?
So, but why is it gray here?
Well, because what that means is we import it in the lead.
So where you got this stuff here
that came from the actual quiz
and where it's imported in like this,
this comes from an import.
Now what's gonna happen is,
and this is what Jim's trying to do,
you're gonna fire off a tag
and you're gonna drop people into this pipeline.
Okay? Well, guess what?
You will not have a quiz here either.
So if I come over here,
and we've done a really good job on this lately,
if I come over here and if I search,
and if I look for this lady here, let me just look for her
by herself, okay?
She's in a popup, at least I think she will.
Is that the right name? Ashley? Hold on.
Let me make sure I'm in my account. I'm not in my account.
I am in my account. See how that works? It's hard for me.
I'm trying to do it where Chrome is in nicely media,
and then Firefox is in his account,
but I keep screwing it up.
So let me come back over here and let's try this browser
and let me see if I can,
or I might just log out just to show you guys.
So, oh, you know what? I could probably just click here.
Alright, so let's try that again.
I'm gonna come over here and I'm gonna
go ahead and search for her again.
And I, and I want you guys to see something. Okay?
So let's search for Ashley.
Okay? So it should find her,
uh, there she is.
Okay. And if I click on detail,
so you can see here's a history where she came in.
Here's the fields that have been assigned to her, right?
So we look at the contact fields.
Uh, here's the form that she completed.
All of her forms will be here.
And then here's the pipeline that she belongs to.
Look at this, guys, look at that.
So even if you come from the contact screen,
even if you were to come from the dashboard,
now look, we can come over here.
This person's submitted, uh, this survey right here. Okay?
I can just go ahead and click from here and look at this.
I can see the form from here.
I can see the pipeline that she was added to from here,
and I can see the stage that she's in, right?
I can see the opportunities,
I can see any notes that have been added.
Is this making sense to you guys?
So you can access all that information from
the contact screen.
You can access it from the dashboard,
you can access it from the pipelines, okay?
But what Jim is looking to do,
and we're close to having it,
is over here under tag actions.
This could be a po, this could be from pop links.
This could be from AI bot studio,
this could be from Letterman, this could be from quiz forma.
This could be from gc.
This could be from anything, anywhere you fire off a tag,
he wants to come over here
and automatically drop 'em into the pipeline, right?
So he wants to be able to choose the pipeline,
and then he wants to be able to choose the stage,
and then he wants to be able to choose the status
and then assign it to an opportunity
and even assign it to a team.
We'll probably have that, we might have it here this week,
but it'll probably be here next week for sure.
Great. And when it great when it drops into the pipeline,
this is a thing, uh, when it drops into your pipeline,
and, uh, it, it's not gonna have a form.
So like, see, this person right here, guys,
this person just came in two hours ago.
Can you tell that this is a hot lead?
Is there, is there anything that sticks
out about that lead right now?
Guys, it'll stay like this for 12 hours
and then it goes away, right?
So if I click on this, it opens up like this,
and now I can see their entire history.
I can see the fields, I can see their tags,
I can see their tag actions.
See this, I can see the form.
They submitted everything here.
So one of those sales guides needs to come in here
and click here and assign themselves
and start working this lead.
And they will. And after 12 hours, this green is gonna turn
to white, and after seven days, it's gonna turn to red.
And you can see that they're assigning activities
to themselves, right?
It's a really, really well done system. Okay?
So the tags and drop it in the pipeline are coming.
But in the meantime, see this one that says import contacts,
let's say, how many business owners are you gonna mail, Jim?
I think there's between 50 and 60 in my first one.
Okay? So let's say the two mile 60,
you get a 20% response rate, right?
Six times two is 12. All right?
So what you could do is take the 12 people that responded,
put 'em into a CSV file,
and then load those 12 people over here
and drop 'em right into your pipeline.
I got that. I definitely could do that.
And one of the reasons I wanna do this is
because when I was in the early days,
way back when quiz former was a lot rougher than it is now.
If you look, I would have like five
or 600 people that viewed the quiz,
but only 210 would take it.
So it would only be like 40% of the people that went
to the quiz took it.
And so I wanna, if they do that
and they don't take the quiz, I want my, um, workflow
to take 'em to a place where I can have a second bite
of the apple and try to find out their, um, name
of their business and their phone number, which lemme see
Something.
Did, did you understand that, Chad?
Did you, was it clear what I'm trying to do?
I think so. Name of the business
and the phone number, I think
so I'm a little confused on something.
I want to go see, uh, what she did,
because you modeled what she was doing at the time.
So, uh, actually,
I don't wanna go this way, I'm gonna go this way.
Okay? So let me get out of, oops.
Let me get out of this bad boy and let me,
okay, so let me come over here and let me see.
Okay, so Archive Summerland,
west Valley shoutouts quiz this one.
This, okay, so 47 people,
okay, let me go look at the statistics first.
So are you a business owner? Yes. I own a business.
39 people. So this is when we had this on the thank you
page, uh, Jim, but you know what though?
Now that I understand this, so, and, and,
and by the way, I was so shocked that this actually worked.
Then I'm in the same boat you are, Jim.
I did nothing with it. It was just an idea.
It was just an idea. Look,
I wasn't even qualifying people at the time.
I was doing exactly like you were.
I was just throwing stuff out there, right?
Yes. Um, art workshops,
jewelry, oh my gosh, yes.
Own a business. Yes. Keep me posted. Let's see.
Are you a business owner? Yes.
Are you interested in networking? Yes. What part of Vegas?
Citywide, but I live in Henderson. How do you advertise?
We need help with our advertising.
Are you interested in being one of our sponsors?
I mean, like, dude, she's pretty much saying sell me
and we didn't sell her, right?
So I'm with you. We need to reengage. Right?
Right. Let me look at another one. Uh, and even
If you go back to that one, she has 200
and whatever it says, 240 views,
but only 47 of those people completed entry.
So I want to find out if I have a second chance
to get those other 200 people.
Yeah. That a lot of people just don't wanna take a quiz.
You get so far and it's like, come on. Yeah.
They don't know what to expect. It
doesn't say three questions.
They think it might be 30 questions in a half an hour. Half.
Yeah. That's why that new, that's why
that new email works really, really well, right?
So imagine that new email, um, if you said, uh,
hey, uh, just curious, you know, uh, one,
I own a business in Northport.
Two, I own a business outside of Northport three,
I'm just a happy go go and restaurant or go
and resident, whatever, right?
And when you click that, Jim, imagine if it took 'em
to a landing page that talks specifically to
that person, right? I
Can build as many pages. Yeah. So
It's great. You're
exactly who I'm looking for.
Uh, if you wouldn't mind, I've got a link down below.
Now that I know you're a business owner, I would love
to align with the businesses in the area.
Could you just take this short little questionnaire for me?
You can see they don't have a
problem taking the questionnaire.
We were just reaching out to everybody, right?
I think the, the micro survey solves that problem.
Now, uh, and I, I gotta go look. Are you, look at this.
Are you interested in being one of our sponsors? Look,
Yes. We are.
Just, we, this, this whole thing took me by shock.
Shock and awe, right? Like, I thought maybe we'd get one
or two, right?
Do you have a list of customers that email frequently?
Yes, I do send out emails. No, I'm not sending out emails.
I'd love to send emails, right?
Uh, is there anything else you'd like to share with us?
Local realtor. We've only been emailing our warm market,
but have thought about starting an email campaign.
Uh, especially realtors such we would love to discuss this
with you and get your advice.
Like they're begging her to call her,
Right? Right.
How, how often does she have time to go back
and check her cosma to find this person about that
Person doesn't like to be honest, guys.
And this is what makes me a horrible marketer, right?
I cracked the code to things, I figure out strategies,
I share 'em with you, and I'm off
to the next thing to help you guys.
And then I come back around, I'm like, holy crap,
that works really, really well.
Right? So, um, which option? Here's another
Thing, Chad, if they, if they take the reg
and then they take the micro survey
and they don't take the quiz, pharma,
you never got their phone number.
You might have, they might have used an email address in
that email address that does not relate to their business.
Yeah, we're gonna fix, and you Might,
you might know they're a business owner,
but what, it's almost like,
what good does it do if you can't get a phone
number or at least the
Name of the business? Yeah, we,
we, we already have
that queued in the micro survey though.
Cool. That's why I'm doing all this roundabout stuff.
I'm, I'm trying to, trying to work with, you know, to,
to get those emails and get those business names
and make sure they're still hot,
and then organize 'em for the first time in my life.
So look, this is the one.
So the other one was for the last publication.
This one's for West Valley. Shout out specifically.
There's 20 people here.
Are you interested in networking with other business owners?
Yes. Keep me posted. 16 of them.
It's so easy to create a meetup in your area, guys. So easy.
How do you advertise word of mouth, 28% social media,
24% local advertising, 14% paid ads, 9% Groupon,
zero email marketing newsletters, 14%.
We don't advertise 2%. We'd love help with our advertising.
Six people. Six people right
there that were waiting for our call.
Mm-hmm. Are you
interested in being one of our sponsors?
There it is again. 14 people, right?
Uh, do you have a list of customers? Yes.
We send out emails. 25%. I'm not sending emails 50%.
I'd love to send emails. 15%, right?
Um,
Yeah, it's, it's insane what we figured out with this
and we really did half pass it.
But you know what though? That's not where, that's not
where she gets all of her people.
And you're not doing this, Jim,
but a lot of people are doing this on the call.
So let me show you, if we come over here to tags,
she has 115 here
that are in Summerland 21 that are outside of Summerland.
And the reason why is because, and lemme see.
So now what would happen is, uh, these 115 people,
uh, and some of 'em are mine doing tests,
but what would happen is these 115 people, okay?
And then these people over here that are not, uh,
in Summerland, um,
those 115 people, if they had submitted,
if they had submitted the survey,
you would see it in the contact records.
Does that make sense? So we gotta get to,
and so the reason why she has so many here is
because in the Facebook group,
uh, Facebook group, yeah.
The Facebook group asks the question,
are you a business owner?
And so a lot are coming from the Facebook group,
Right? Right,
Right. Yep.
So, but even, I mean, you can see
that we started out good and then we forgot about it, right?
Need help with email.
10 people need help advertising 18 people, right?
I think maybe we tagged sponsor. I, I don't know.
Like I, I, I really don't know.
We didn't do very good with it.
I was just really trying to throw some things out there,
guys and see how it works.
So if you look at the different ways, um,
this is why this is so important to me.
And so I'll show you what, um, uh,
I'll show you what, uh, let me see if she's got any, oh,
I gotta get outta my account.
Hold on a second. Let me get
into the other account.
Hold on. And I'm bouncing back
and forth between four different accounts
and it gets confusing.
And then, and sometimes I gotta go
log into your guys' stuff.
Okay? So survey response is, uh, come on Now.
Did I log in on mine? I logged in as me.
Hold on a second, guys. Let's see. I
Okay.
Survey responses.
Uh, west Valley.
Nope. I hers was off, right?
Have you, have you had people filling this out? Jim?
Um, none the business. Outside. Outside, I'm a resident.
I'm a resident. I'm a resident. I'm a resident.
I own a business outside. I'm a resident.
I'm a, I own a business outside. I own a business outside.
I own a business in Summerlin. Uh, but that was me,
Right? I've got a few, but
I haven't committed
to completely doing this
because again, I, I'm not collecting a phone number.
Mm-hmm. So I know that, okay, this guy's a, a,
a business in, in, in Summerland,
but you know, he signed up as, uh, you know, uh,
why me@gmail.com.
And that doesn't tell me who he is
or what his business is or anything like that.
So I haven't completely committed to that.
That's why I want to try to get the tag in there
for the time being just get the tag in there
and I don't really care what their notes are.
Once I know that they're still interested
and they've reached out by Elise responding to an email,
then I don't mind picking up the phone saying, oh yeah,
that email I sent you a couple
that Dave sent you a couple days ago.
I wanted to talk to you about that.
I mean, look, I can add that to here,
but it's gonna hurt your conversions.
Well, maybe, but my other mint bird page has both
and I'm getting good conversions there.
So maybe actually, I really want to have both going.
One of them I want to use for the secondary sources,
like Nextdoor and this other thing that I'm working on,
and then the embedded one for the people that come
through the traditional avenues.
So I'd like to get 'em both working eventually so
that I can break out how many people are coming
through next door or how many people are coming in
through these other, other ways.
And then how we'll
Probably just do this. Are you
on the call right now, G
Are you still here, Jamie? I, I,
I even thought about just changing my micro survey.
Instead of tell me about your business,
just say, what is your phone number?
Why do I need to know? Are you interested in advertising?
Tell me about your business.
No, just gimme your phone number,
then I can collect the phone number.
But I'm not sure where that would go in the micro survey,
how it would show up in a tag or anything.
Well, we would just have to have a checkbox that said,
this is a phone number so we would know to
Right. Phone
number. Um, and we could get cut
Off, cut off the presses.
That's the one we really want, not the ones we go back
and reclaim, right?
Yeah. Probably what will end up happening is we'll put
another box here and just ask them
for the business name and their phone number.
You probably don't like talking to me very much, Chad.
No, but that's if we've already been
talking about this, right?
Because we know, we know
that we can get people from the Facebook group
and you know, we can get people from
that micro survey, right?
We know those things are working.
They're working a hundred percent without a doubt.
And we know that when they take a quiz.
See, to me, I don't know, man, to me,
I don't think I would drop anybody in a
pipeline till they've taken a quiz.
'cause they're telling me they're serious
and they've given us lots of information,
Information. Well, I
still say people are lazy
when it comes to quizzes.
I know I am.
Yeah, you say that, but yeah,
you just saw those responses.
Yeah. And not only that, you, you saw
where people were asking for help,
you saw where people were asking for help, right?
But if I, if I saw a form
or a link in, in a, in a workflow email, I'd know it's
coming from Reliable Source and I could just click that link
and end up with a tag.
But on the other hand, without a form in that email,
you're still not gonna collect their email address.
I mean, their phone number or the name of their business.
Um, yeah, I'm thinking on that.
I, I would send out that email.
I, I would try to reengage as many people as you can.
But you, you know, this from three years ago, Jim,
keep track of how many you sent it to,
how many people opened, how many people replied, right?
Yep. I wanna know.
We wanna know what those conversions are, for sure.
But I'll tell you,
there's something to this man.
There was something to, there was some magic.
I'm gonna tell you guys right now, there's some magic
that we were doing, uh, over here on this page.
There really freaking was
because this is how people, this is how people took
that, that quiz,
Right?
It was this right here. This is
how we were getting those business
owners, right?
So I was getting more local business owners this way.
Now, through the quiz, I'm getting more
outside business owners, which is weird, right?
Um, but yeah, there's some, there's some magic
to having this as your thank you page
and then putting people in the quiz.
You're right now, mama got you. And your babies,
Right? So,
um, yeah,
we definitely need to, I definitely need to figure this out.
I'm just gonna go and put the ask for the business name
and the phone number and the micro survey.
Um, does anybody have that micro survey turned on right now
that's running ads or that
that has traffic hitting their page?
Anybody at all?
Do any of you guys, I'm just curious what your results are
as you can see outside of Summerland, okay?
That's the same person though. Let's see. I'm a resident.
I'm a resident. I'm a resident. I'm a resident, right?
I own a business outside. I'm a resident.
I own a business outside.
There was like nobody, like,
I don't understand why they're all coming from outside.
I'm just collecting lead doesn't go to Page.
Yeah, but do you have anybody telling you
that they are a business in your area, Robert?
And they're, they're, they're filling this information in.
Um, and, and, and by the way,
after my training, I want you guys to know this,
uh, after my training,
Uh, Where would she have put that?
Oh, it won't be in this one.
After my training the other day of doing the, um,
this one, let me see if it's this one.
I think it's this one maybe. Yeah. Okay, so this is the one.
Don't tell her I showed you this, but
after I did the Hustle 2.0 training, I said something
that made a lot of sense.
And I said, if you take everything you learned in 1.0
and combine it with what I'm teaching you in 2.0,
then you have a pretty amazing newsletter.
And so I told Connie, I said, I want you to get back to
what you used to do
and then supplement it with the articles.
And so you can see, uh, and,
and by the way, we were, we were at, uh,
PJ's restaurant the other day, uh,
when she was making these images with Chad GPT.
You guys see this? Those are all Chad GPT images, right?
So now she doesn't have to worry about copyright
or anything, but I told her,
and even this one, I told her, I said, I want you
to get back to what you did,
but then just supplement it
with the articles, Right?
So she's going back to where we started, um,
and then she's gonna go through
and supplement it with the articles,
and I think that's just gonna be the
most incredible newsletter,
Right?
Um, so yeah, that's, that's the one that's going out.
Um, yeah, Chad, GPT has definitely stepped up, uh, in 5.2.
You can just take this thumbnail here
and give it to Chad, GPT and say, recreate this
and make sure it's Summerland.
And it'll do it right. It'll, it'll do it.
And you don't have to worry about copyright or anything.
Like, and, you know, remember your avatar,
45, 60 5-year-old women, they're okay.
They're not like, is that t no, they're not thinking
that way, right?
So, all right.
Um, anyways, going back to where we started, Jim,
I would be, I would be more than happy for her to take all
of her tags
and send this out out as long
as she's prepared to reply to him.
So the question is, when you connect with them,
whatcha gonna do next?
I'm gonna reach out to 'em.
I just wanna know that they're receptive to a phone call
and that it's not another nag cold call from someone else.
If they've seen that email recently, they'll realize
that it's a reaction from the email.
That's it. That's all I want.
Once I start talking to 'em,
I think I can close a certain percentage of them
and I can get rid of my, you know, um,
hip pocket advertisers
and replace 'em with retail price advertisers.
That's the goal.
I'm gonna tell you right now. I still think, I still think
the biggest opportunity you have is
present right here.
That's it. Right there.
Mm-hmm. That's it right there.
Jim put together a monthly meetup.
They want to network with other business owners,
and you can be the one running that.
And what's crazy about this, I did this in Wyoming,
is when you put together those people, they'll, uh,
volunteer venues and stuff, right?
They'll be, Hey, you can do it over here at our law firm.
Hey, we can do it over here at the Breakfast House.
Like, I was really surprised how many people reached out
and said, Hey, do you wanna help with the venue?
We did the first one at the chiropractor's, uh, studio.
But I think that's the best way is
to tackle all of them at once.
And then when you get the people there, invite them
to bring other people to the venue, right?
Mm-hmm. Yep.
How realistic is it to do something like that?
No, I think it's definitely realistic.
You know, if, if, if,
if I could have used quiz form perfectly right from the
start, I wouldn't be looking at this.
Um, but, you know, my logic was wrong in a couple
of questions, and they were residents
and they were getting asked business questions,
so they went in as business tags,
and they weren't really business people, so I had to go back
and eliminate them manually.
It's just, you know,
what I'm trying to do? I'm just trying to organize.
Can I look at your, can I look at your quiz for,
Uh, yeah, I've got a dozen,
I've got a dozen of them in there.
That's okay. I, I keep playing with trying a new one
or trying a different one, but yes, absolutely.
You can always look at my stuff. Chad. Absolutely.
Pne, can you send me his access real quick?
PNE or G?
Yeah. Okay. Thanks.
Um, let's go look at it
and see what we're dealing with first,
because I thought I was the first
one to give you that quiz, right?
The, um, the response, the response
to that quiz, guys is really, really high.
Like that thank you page saying we're looking
to align with business owners.
That was, that's where we got all of our submissions from.
The jury's still out on the micro survey.
I can't see how it wouldn't
work, right?
But the other thing that we have to figure out,
and I'm trying to get to it, is just throwing ads right
to the registration page so
that we get the co-reg to open up.
And I think that would be a true game changer too,
but we haven't even tried doing that yet.
Uh, let's see. Did you send it to me on Zoom over here?
Yes. It's near DM In my dm. Okay. Hold on a second.
Uh,
okay, perfect.
Okay.
Um,
did I spell something wrong?
You bill on my gmail do com.
Oh, I missed a u Hold on a second.
Okay,
so Venice matters.
All right, let's go look at this one.
View statistics, please tell me the name of your business.
Okay?
So hold on a minute. 23 answers, and there's how many?
Two or 24 entries. I see what you mean.
Okay, so let me go look at,
Uh, yeah, port Charlotte and North Port get better action.
They're bigger towns, so either one
of those you'll find probably bigger numbers and,
and better stuff you can use.
Yeah, so you got, you got 19.
You, you have 19 that you know for sure.
Probably 23 that you know for sure,
but I don't have one.
So this,
I think from this one, you have 19 that you know for sure,
but let me see, how do you advertise?
16, 17? Yeah.
Um, report. I did not send down emails.
Is there anything else you'd like to share with us?
Where did these people come from? Jim?
Uh, interesting.
Are you still there, Jim?
Yes. I didn't realize I shut it off.
Pam was hit with me and her phone was going off.
Um, yeah, they probably came in through Facebook directly,
or the alternative would be they came in
through the extension that we were using at that time.
If you look at this here, um,
I think you have 20 business owners in here
just looking at the answers.
12 plus eight.
Uh,
I think there's 20 in here.
So this was from
the, uh, you said it, it was from Lead Snigger.
What was it from?
Probably from Lead Snigger or,
or, uh, just sending people to my Facebook page to sign up.
I was doing that back then too.
So you would, to get people sign up on your Facebook page,
you sent 'em to here first?
I would send them to my signup page, directly
to my signup page from Facebook, directly to my signup page.
And what I'm trying to understand
is how did they take the quiz?
Was it a follow up email?
Yes. Oh, yeah. Yes. I have two or three, um, emails.
Oh, oh, it flat out says the neighborhood survey.
So you meant for this to be
for the community from the very start?
Yep. Okay. All right.
Let me look at, I think you have 20 business
owners in there that I would tackle.
I wouldn't try to, I I would just go through
and pull those business owners outta there,
Jim. I think there's 20 of them.
Go to page two, And I wouldn't even mess
with these other 200 people. You see what I'm saying?
Right? Yep. Okay. Now which one?
Uh, go to page two on the, this one, the second page.
Second page of my quizzes.
Oh, page two. Okay.
And now you should see some bigger numbers there
for Port Charlotte and North Port.
So I had like, is this
A neighborhood Neighborhood?
That's the same thing. That's the same thing
just for a bigger town.
So you were trying to use the quiz
to sort, sift and separate?
Yes. See, and here's one
where I, I couldn't get rid of the logo.
Uh, some I could, some I couldn't. I'm not sure why.
Maybe it's 'cause an older version
or, uh, maybe that one I tried last summer
and I've got a newer one I can do it in.
I'm not sure like that.
This one, What is, so nevermind.
That's my own stupidity. Nevermind.
That's okay. But, um, hold on, let me look.
Please tell us about yourself. How long you lived in.
Are you a business owner or manager?
Okay, so let's go look, let's go look at that one.
Okay, that one's positioned a little bit better.
So, you know, you got 28 people here,
Right?
So I would take the 28.
I don't even think I would try to find, oh,
is there a business owner in here?
I would just take their word for it right now, right?
Um, how do you advertise referrals?
So look, you got 31 there,
37, right?
You probably have 40 people in here. Yep. And you got 19.
Yeah. So 5 34 C
34 plus five.
I'm telling you, you got about 40 people in here. Mm-hmm.
You can see 'em, right? Like,
I would take these people here.
I, I would take these people here.
These are the people that I would target.
Jim, I would only target the people that,
that are indicating to you
that they're business owners and that's it.
I would not, and, and I think, um, and those,
Those are the people that I would send that email out to,
to find out if they're still active.
Still warm and try to
Yeah. So you're not,
you're not going to, okay, that's good.
So I thought you were gonna send an email
to all 292 people. No,
No, no, no, no, no. Just for one.
Oh, so you're gonna go through and pick and choose Yes.
What you think. Yeah, that's the right thing to do.
That's the right thing to do.
Um, so and where's the other one? This one?
Yeah, those are the three.
Those are the big three that from way back when,
from back in, you know, July
and August when we first started playing around
with quiz formula, when it was still really an unfinished
product, uh, usable, but, you know, had little things to it.
So, so I was using it,
but I never paid attention to it.
I mean, I had no follow up. That's my fault.
I'm busy, I get other things to do,
but now it's time to go back and I got the ad newspaper
and newspaper, the newsletter where I want it.
Now I need to go back and focus on selling to these people
and generating more of these people.
And, you know, I look at the, the quiz
and I don't really care where they advertise.
I just want to know that they're business owners
and they do advertise whether they use Yelp or whatever.
That's all good. But once I get on the phone with 'em,
I'll find that out Anyway,
I think, I think just looking at this briefly,
I think you have about 75 business owners here,
Right? I do too.
I think I've got about 80
or 85 somewhere in there based on my tags.
Yeah. So, uh, you're gonna create three tags
called business prospects, probably send out this email
Hot tags, right?
And what you might do is you might do a test.
You might say, Hey, Chuck, Dave from Northport Matters, uh,
you look into Join our Business Roundup or something,
Right? I could do that
too. Yep.
Find out which one connects best.
Is it gonna be the, the, the, the networking?
And by the way, the key, what I figured out guys,
what do you think the number one thing, uh,
a business owner wants with some kind of meetup?
What do you think the number one thing is?
There's one thing that they want more than anything,
Than training information.
Nope. Nope.
Not leases, not customers. Nope. Nope.
There's one word I want you guys to remember.
There it is, right there. See what Keith just said?
They want to network.
So when you, if you were to do that, Jim, you say, Hey,
you are looking to join my, uh, business networking event
here in Northport, right?
Mm-hmm. Uh, and that's, that's what they want.
So find out if is, is, um, is this the right hook
or are you looking to, uh, would you like to, you know,
join my business networking event here in Northport,
find out which one does best.
I'd, I'd send out like one to one tag, one to the other one,
and then see what works best, right?
Um, but yeah, that's what I would do.
You can very easily take those answers
and then tag those people.
You just import 'em back in, tag them as prospects,
and then, uh, you know,
you can put 'em in a workflow and then freeze it.
Or you can just send out a broadcast,
Right?
Whatever it is you wanna do, right? So I think
you have a plan.
Um, now it's a matter of
what are gonna discuss with 'em on the phone.
Whatcha are you gonna discuss with I can
Lead, I can,
I think I can lead a phone conversation wherever I want.
If I can get to know 'em. I've been in town a long time.
They might know my name. They definitely know my newsletter.
Yeah, I mean, you're trying to get sponsors out of it.
You're trying to get advertisers, you're gonna run lead ads
for 'em, you're gonna do email or just all the above,
Right? Right.
Yep.
Um, and that's why that question on the survey,
I think we have it on ours now, that says,
what do you think you are struggling with most?
Well, based on what they say,
we can put together a plan, right?
But the cool thing is, what I'm hoping guys, is
with our suite, you can put together a plan pretty fast.
That's what I'm hoping. That's what I'm hoping.
So, um, yeah, I think all this looks good.
What else can I do to help?
Well, let me have g for about three days.
No, I'm only kidding. Um, no,
I'm on it ju I'm definitely on it.
Uh, the other thing is, how many people do you have?
I know you're not ready to do this, but I'm just curious,
how many people do you have from like, all your groups
and solo ads and stuff like that?
Oh, in my GC I've got 9,000 people almost.
I'm pushing 10,000 people now.
About 5,000 of 'em are subscribers.
And they're, you know, with a good portion
of those being active,
but the rest of them are all previous solo ad people.
And who knows
where else they came from over the last year, year and a half.
I need to reengage those.
So I've been paying close attention
to using Sprout to doing that. I've got,
You see that You did A-G-P-T-I, I saved it.
And just today I was looking at it thinking I've got to,
I've gotta take these steps. So, yeah.
Well, I need to do that, um, that infill video
with you too on your course.
Yep, For sure.
So I can keep, you know, I, like, even the other day guys,
I, I put, um, I spent eight hours building out that course,
and I just let Zoom go.
I don't know where it's at. I just over here somewhere.
I just let Zoom go for,
uh, my Vimeo or my Zoom automatically loads into Vimeo.
So somewhere here, team Library, let me see.
Zoom, uh, I'll show you.
I have to find the time to, to break it up,
but at least I named the, the meeting, right?
So, uh, somewhere over here,
there's been a lot that's happened since,
uh, temporary Zoom.
Oh, it's gonna be in here probably.
I just recorded all day,
like I invited you guys to hop on or whatever.
And then I did my best to answer.
But see here, 2.0 build out right here,
and then 2.0 build out, look at this thing, six hours
and 29 minutes, four hours and 18 minutes.
So I've just recorded for 10 hours.
And if you don't think I'm not gonna take that
and drop that into Course Sprout.
And some of you're gonna sit there
and watch a 10 hour recording.
I know you will, right? But look how easy that was.
Like, I didn't even have to,
it was the most boring recording you'll ever watch.
But we built a course in a day in 10 hours
with full gamification and everything.
Uh, I'll tell you guys, uh, what they did last night, I have
to now lay it out on the front end,
but wherever that, um, hold on a second.
Wherever that went, let me show you guys.
Uh, where'd It go? Uh, I'll just go this way then.
Let me get back in.
Yeah, wherever that pod was.
Um, is this a different one now or this is a different one?
Dang it. I keep writing or logging the same one.
Okay. Profile picture
a save.
Okay. Uh, used
to do video marketing locally filmed about 200 mini
doc for review sites.
I helped few local business owners Like this just came in
44 minutes ago, guys.
Paul just earned a badge.
Like, do this stuff, do this stuff, right? Just do it.
Um, but what I was gonna tell you is
tonight, I'm gonna lay it out.
We already did the API last night where when you click
inside of here, uh,
you're also gonna have resources down below.
So you'll have a resource library
just like we did with Everlast.
So you can pull in your resources over and over
and over and over and over, right?
So I'm doing everything I can to, um,
you have all the bare basics that we have with Everlast
because everybody loved, um, that software.
But this is, this is turning out
to be a pretty incredible software.
Um, the other thing I wanted to mention to you guys
is, uh, there, I made a post the other day
and I got a lot of people reaching out to me,
and they wanted to know about that ai,
uh, software that we were using.
So I'm gonna explain this. I'm explaining the drama that,
uh, came from all that.
So, uh, this year, Claude takes over just
so you guys know it's gonna happen, right?
I believe it's gonna happen. Uh, it's just astronomical,
the difference in quality.
Um, but, uh, somebody went
and created an open source, uh, app, uh, called Claude,
C-L-A-W-D bought.
And if, if ever there was a time I was finally ahead
of something, I went and we bought Claude worship
shop.com, right?
We got it. Like we got it right, right away.
Claude bought workshop.
And then, uh, later that day,
there was a seasoned desist from Claude, right?
The official Claude, they came
after him, said, you have to change the name.
And in the time that they were changing their Bitbucket
name, uh,
and something else, they were changing their domain
or whatever, uh, these hackers came in
and basically took control of the Bitbucket, took control
of the name, and then they
went out there since the name has.
So all kinds of popularity started selling a coin
and whatever else happens in the crypto world started
ripping people off and everything else.
So now this thing has a black eye. Alright?
So they went in a day from naming it from Claude bought to,
um, mbo, right?
Well, here's what this does.
And what I talked about the other day is gonna
be reality this year.
It's using the Claude platform,
and, uh, it has all of these built in skills.
So I've been telling everybody for the past 10 years,
the very best thing you can do, especially
after COVID, was develop skills.
Now the business is getting to the point where, uh,
you're not gonna have to develop the skills.
You just need to run the AI that controls the skills.
So right now, as I'm speaking,
and I'll probably show this to you guys next week,
I have WhatsApp and I have my, uh, telegram
where I am talking to, uh,
I'm talking, oh, I named it Pacino, of course,
but I'm talking to Pacino over here.
And, uh, he's learning about our business.
He's learning about, uh, our software suite.
Uh, he's learning about our calls.
Um, he's learning about my history,
he's learning about our audience.
He's learning as much as he can about our business so
that he's able to turn around
and say, Hey, uh, don't forget,
we gotta get the replay out tonight.
Hey, don't forget, we gotta send an email for this.
Hey, don't forget, we got the seven day promo coming up.
And he keeps me and my team on track, right?
So what they've done, and just to clarify this, and,
and you probably heard all this drama about vulnerabilities
in code and everything else, guys, listen, man, you're,
you're hearing from people that know zero about code.
There's people out there talking about Bitbucket
and GitHub that don't even know what it does.
They don't know, they didn't know anything about code
until they were able to type something in that says,
build me a software that does this.
So they know nothing about security.
They know nothing about vulnerabilities.
They know nothing about the stuff that we deal
with on a day-to-day basis.
And what my post is about is, I said,
but hey, you better accept that fact.
'cause guess what? You got people that are not trained
that know nothing about security or vulnerabilities
or anything, and they're building out software
with like vibe coding and stuff,
and it's deploying to, uh, GitHub
and it's deploying on a server.
And that software's going out there and,
and collecting personal information.
And the ver you know, you don't have the security in place,
you don't have the protocols in place.
Like there's, that's gonna be a huge backlash, right?
So, so expect that.
So when I hear that there's vulnerabilities in this system,
first of all, I'm gonna tell you right now that, uh,
there was no way in hell I was ever going to,
even when everybody's excited about this, there was no way
I was going to install this thing on my system.
Why would I do that? Why would
I give it access to everything I have?
No, the first thing we did
before anybody else was to set up a VPS.
Now, I didn't set up an Amazon S3 VPS
and pay thousands of dollars,
and I certainly didn't go buy a $10,000 Apple book.
And I wasn't gonna get the micro like, screw that.
We're paying $35 for a VPS
that is now I can now access from, uh, I can talk
to this cloud bot thing from Telegram and WhatsApp,
and probably by the end of the day, I'll be able
to do it from, uh, iMessage as well, right?
Just from my phone. And so it's reminding me, Hey,
don't forget you got the mastermind call today, right?
And it's coming up with the headline for the call, right?
And so what happens is once it learns everything about your
business, okay,
and it learns about your local business,
it learns about your newsletter
and everything else, they have trained this bot
on certain skills.
And so what happens is you give it access
to say Google Drive, you give it access to Dropbox,
you give it access to Nana Banana, whatever
that thing is, it creates the images.
You give it access to 11 labs, right?
So it has access to where it can go in there
and it's already trained to use the software.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So you pretty much just go through
and you choose the skill that you want to have,
and it takes everything that is learned from you
and is basically using that skill like it would
for anybody else, but it's applying
your situation.
So like, it knows we're a software company,
it knows we're an online education company.
It knows that we do like a lot of trainings
and a lot of calls and a lot
of workshops and a lot of launches.
So it's, it's learning from that.
But the cool thing is we also see where it is, uh,
correcting itself, which is pretty fascinating, right?
If I spell out, Hey, um, you know, this wasn't right,
then it'll correct itself.
And, but not like, not like Chad GPT guys.
This thing actually remembers things like when we went from,
uh, WhatsApp to Telegram, the first thing it said is,
oh man, I'm happy you're over here on Telegram too,
because WhatsApp was getting
kind of heavy and dah, dah, dah, dah.
The responses were slow.
And, and so it was changing the models for me.
So we went and created its own email address.
First of all, it's on a VPS, okay?
So it only gets access to what I want to give it access to.
It doesn't get access to my whole system.
So if there is some conspiracy behind that
or whatever, oh, well, it just has access to the VPS
that we're paying $35 a month.
I plan on showing you how to set all this stuff up, guys.
'cause I think it's pretty fascinating,
but it's a little techy, it's a little heavy.
So we're trying to go through and figure out all the
obstacles and everything that's gonna stop you.
Um, but for 35 bucks a month, that's how we can,
you can literally open up your phone and,
and say, Hey, don't forget, you gotta,
you gotta finish your newsletter.
Uh, hey, don't forget, you don't wanna miss Chad's call.
You see what I'm saying?
Like, it's gonna do all that for you.
So we're learning about the skills that it currently has,
and it can do its own vibe coding, right?
It can do cloud code, it can,
we're learning about all the skills
that it currently has boxed in right now, okay?
And then what's gonna happen is people are creating
plugins for new skills.
So what does that mean?
How many of you're starting to connect the dots right now?
What does that mean? That means if I understand everything
properly, and I, I've done a lot of research
and a lot of testing, talked to a lot
of people, I think I got it.
That means that we should be able to make a plugin
for freaking Letterman.
We should be able to make a plugin for gc.
We should be able to make a plugin for Bert
and whatever documentation needs to go with it to
where you're able to go and actually install those plugins.
That's what we're banking on this year, guys,
where everything that I've been teaching you in the
mastermind and, uh, relying on you to do, and,
and for whatever reason, you're like, stuck in your head
or not clear, can't come up with a copy and,
and scared to ask me on a call.
Like whatever reason this thing is gonna do it for you
and say, Hey, how's, how's the page?
How's it look? How's the headline?
And you're just gonna be like, push the button, right? Go.
Um, so it's pretty fascinating.
We have it, um, like analyzing sheets.
We have it like loading videos, uh, you know,
it's doing stuff in Google Drive, uh,
like we're just getting our feet wet
with it, but it's pretty phenomenal.
Like, you can go through your email and,
and it can determine, hey, you know, this is a problem.
We gotta deal with this. I say, okay, write me a draft for
that, and they'll send the draft.
Okay, perfect. Send it like you, you know what I mean?
Like, it can, it's, it's pretty amazing.
It, it's, it's a lot different.
Chad, GPT, and I've always told you this, you gotta feed it.
You gotta feed it. And what was Chad GPT good for?
Well, first of all, I like to brainstorm
and I like to use it as a friend.
I was feeling pretty discouraged last night
and I started talking to it or whatever,
and I felt better when I left, right?
But so, uh, you know, you can use it to build you up,
give you ideas, encourage you,
but it's also good for like copy and, and stuff like that.
Not as good as Claude, not as good as Gemini,
but it's good, right?
Um, this is different. This is different.
This thing keeps you on track,
but there's a lot you need to know with it.
For instance, as soon as I set it up, uh,
I said, tell me about your company.
I'm like, sure. I came in business in 1998,
my favorite actor's Al Pacino, Hey,
I'm gonna name you Pacino.
And I just went through and I, I typed this big thing
and I went and looked
because I was using the very best model,
and it was like, boom, four bucks.
Like, I just, like, I just put it in a slot machine.
And I was like, whoa, this sink can get expensive, right?
Well, it's because you gotta train yourself,
and I'm gonna help you guys do this
because it's not like cha PT where you're like talking back
and forth, back and forth, back and forth.
Everything you type becomes a prompt.
And if you tell it to memorize something,
it'll re it'll memorize it in the bank.
Like I've always told you guys, if you have an idea
or whatever, write it down, get it outta your head.
Well, now you can say to Pacino
or whatever, Hey, do me a favor, put
that in your memory bank and
they'll put it in your memory bank.
But it's using tokens to do all this stuff.
So you need to get clear on, you know,
what models do you use for when, right?
Uh, you need to get clear on how to, uh, respond properly so
that you know it's the least,
it's the most cost effective for you.
Um, and so we're gonna be covering all this
because I do believe that, uh, it is the future
of our business, right?
And I don't think, uh, I'm watching, I'm,
I'm watching these gurus
and I'm watching the advice they're giving or whatever.
And it's like, so stupid, right? So stupid, right?
Like, you would never put something
untested in your own system.
Like why would you do that? You would never do that, right?
Vulnerabilities, don't use it. Don't use it.
Red alert, red alert, red alert.
There's vulnerabilities,
there's security issues, da da da da.
Yeah. And there was, with our software, there was
with course route, there was with every, there was
with go high level, it's
with all software vulnerabilities are there.
You, you, you don't know
because there's a million different scenarios.
You don't know until you put it out there
and go, whoa, that happened, then you fix it.
The problem is when you don't fix vulnerabilities,
which is a lot of JV Z launches, okay?
So they're gonna fix it. They're gonna fix it.
I ain't worried about some stupid stealing the name.
I'm not worried about taking the name
and doing a crypto launch.
I, I don't care about none of that.
It's a good quality platform, the very best case
of AI I've ever seen.
And we're all aboard. We are a thousand percent in,
and when I bring this to you guys, I will not bring it
to you where you'll be vulnerable.
I will not bring it to you where it's dangerous.
I'll bring it to you where it's MVP, where it is, uh, very,
very cost effective, right?
Um, and yeah, you'll learn,
you'll know everything about that.
So you don't make the same mistakes we're making right now.
We're making a lot of mistakes
that are costing us a lot of money.
Let us do that. That's why we do that, right?
Um, because we're also documenting everything.
We're also learning from everything. Okay?
So does that kind of answer your questions and what that is?
I've been, you have a lot of questions.
I haven't had time to answer everybody one-on-one.
Uh, but that's what it's gonna do. And our plan is to, uh,
create these skills, create these skills
so they'll work specifically for our suite.
I don't think we'll be the only one thinking this way.
I am sure that go high level's thinking that, Hey,
we gotta create a plugin.
Like I'm sure everybody's thinking this way, okay?
But I also think that what we create is pretty simple.
And so it's gonna work pretty good, right?
And I think this thing will write newsletters for you.
Uh, I I think it's gonna be pretty incredible.
There's one more thing I wanna mention too
before I let you guys go.
There's gonna be an update that hits today.
I'll show you an image of it, uh,
because I think it's pretty extraordinary.
Um, let me see if I can find it over here.
Um, let me see if I can find this.
Where is that? Uh, it was done yesterday
and I'm told that this will be up today.
Uh, is it an update? Lemme check the Letterman room.
I feel like we have cracked the code to something.
Uh, pretty incredible. Uh, is it an update?
Maybe it's in UI room. Hold on a second. Ui.
Um, well,
coffee gave me a real one,
but I'm just gonna show you guys this for now.
I don't know where you put it, but this will be live today.
You guys will see it. Um,
do you guys see a screen right here?
So for the top 10 where it says most recent sends,
this will show the latest one.
And this will be real data.
This was the screen I started with,
but this will be live today.
Uh, this will be real data.
And so it's gonna tell you the last time
that this newsletter was sent,
or, yeah, so it'll be the most recent send.
And then this will tell you how many peers are subscribed
and how many of 'em are actually, uh, engaged.
Okay? So let me just ask you guys,
um, and I'll get to that.
Chris, let me just ask you guys,
am I on the wrong screen again? Hold on a second. Maybe
You, you're on the self-mastery co-sign in page.
I meant to be on this one. Okay.
Is that, is that better now? Yep.
I'm seeing 'em now. Publication directory.
Yes. So this is static,
but first of all, we have the switch here,
where now you could show only the unsubscribed.
So when you plug in your email, you flip the switch on,
it'll show you, you want this number, you're subscribed.
Matching this number over here. Okay?
But what's gonna happen is the most
recent send will be over here.
And not only that, for the top, for the 10
that have most recently sent, we're gonna show you
how many peers are subscribed
and how many of those peers are active.
And so that way, every single time somebody sees this,
they see the potential, they see what we're doing,
and, uh, they wanna start sending out their newsletter
because you can only get
to the top if you're sending out your newsletter.
Does that make sense to you guys?
I think that is gonna be a true game changer.
Uh, I definitely think that
that feature right there is gonna have people sending their
newsletter for sure.
Because the whole idea behind
that is the more peers you have, the more you're gonna go
to the inbox, especially with what we're doing, uh,
every single week right now.
Let me, uh, address you, Chris.
There was, uh, as far as that DFY suite, it's gone back
and forth two times.
I'm waiting for a response, hopefully tomorrow.
Uh, they came back and said there was a problem
because the keywords were capitalized
or something, I don't know.
So we went back
and we're like, they're like, okay,
it's been fixed from this point forward.
I'm like, yeah, but what about the site maps that we have
that are already existing?
How do we get them back in the system?
And then we had to make some changes,
and then we submitted it to them,
and then we're waiting on the feedback.
So we're hot and heavy
with the keywords like I talked about.
Uh, matter of fact, I can probably show you guys that,
but we're also hot and heavy with the submission right now.
It's just, unfortunately it's a little bit of back and forth
because that AI was a little bit harder than
I thought it was gonna be.
Um, but we're, we're definitely gonna get it.
We're definitely gonna get it right.
And I don't know if I have that popup where I can show you.
Yeah, I don't think they put it in the
new UI channel, did they?
I, um, but yeah, that, that thing with Josh
is, is pretty exciting.
It's, it's a pretty big deal. So, um, I'm on top of that.
It's just a lot of back and forth
with the developers right now.
That's all it is. So, uh, we will have it soon enough.
So, uh, anyways, guys,
I hope you got a lot of value outta that.
Is that good? Did you guys get a lot of value?
Get some ideas like now, you know,
we're still gonna keep building our list.
We're gonna reengage our old list.
The, uh, red light, green light, really,
really important in our system.
Autoresponders are scams, right?
Um, we helped Jim with that email.
I'm gonna give that email to Connie too.
I know he is gonna get a response.
Uh, we'll set up the tag for him so
that they can drop in the pipeline.
Um, and, uh, uh, Josh,
you have a link to that.
You have a link to the Mastermind.
Uh, usually when I get go high level
people in here, they don't last.
I am not complicated enough for them, right?
Uh, but I can, if you can't find it,
I can send you a link personally.
Um, we've had a few go high level people in here,
and then they, they, they don't, they don't like me,
they don't like me, they don't like our software.
It's too simple for them.
You know, I, I've, I've understood that there's people that,
um, now know that, hey, these are necessary tools
to be profitable in my business.
And then there's people that really like
to spend a lot of time in tech.
I'm not a guy that likes
to spend a lot of time in tech guys.
I want to do the bare, minimal necessary
to get the biggest bang for my buck.
And I'm now like more about Netflix
and going out to dinner and stuff like that.
I'm not a techie guy, believe it or not, right?
So I build the MVP, I believe
that I build exactly what's the most important, right?
To get the, the best result.
So, uh, but I'll look for that link. I'll send it to you.
And, uh, yeah, everything we talked about AI guys, we're,
we're on track with that.
We're gonna do that. So, uh, probably maybe Friday,
I'm gonna ask everybody if you'll give it some thought, uh,
in addition to like that there, uh, you know, like what,
what we're doing with MBO and all that other stuff.
You know, I plan on getting into teaching you how
to do slides with ai, uh, plan 'em.
We, we gotta go back
and visit the, um, the, uh,
personal avatar thing now, right?
Building out your clone, all that stuff.
I gotta do all that stuff
to keep everybody in the green, right?
So you guys are gonna benefit from it too,
but I'm gonna ask everybody like what they would like
to see, but understand this man,
the stuff that pays our bills is the red light, green light,
the course sprout showing up on these calls.
Old outdated strategies on new simple tech.
If all I had was showing people how to do AI
or whatever the next shiny thing was,
and I didn't have a button on the page,
how would I get paid?
How would I get paid, right?
So don't forget that, especially you guys we're gonna
venture into the new stuff I got to,
to keep everybody in the green.
But ultimately, look how many
of you guys have ever heard me say, uh, give 'em
what they want, sell 'em what they need.
Anybody ever heard that?
Give 'em what they want, sell 'em what they need.
So look, somebody comes in
and they're gonna join our workshop,
and we're gonna, we're gonna, uh, we're gonna suffer
through it, but we're gonna show 'em how
to set up A-A-A-V-P-S and give 'em the steps and,
and teach 'em how to train it
and how to plug in the different models
and all this other stuff.
And, and we're gonna do all that stuff, right?
And then somebody's gonna have all of it.
And then, then they're gonna go through like 20 bucks in,
in an hour or whatever.
And then they're gonna, oh, man,
this stuff gets kind of expensive, man.
How do I, and the first thing they're gonna say to me,
how do I, how, how do I make money with this?
Yeah, that's what they're gonna say.
That's what, what everybody says.
How do I make money with this?
How do I make see after they're done playing,
after they discover, oh wow, he helped me get there.
He showed me how to do this.
He showed me how to do Offerman,
but how, how, how do I make money with this Chad?
Well, now you need to pay very, very close attention.
'cause now that I showed you that we can get you
through the, the shiny object, the thing that you wanted.
Let's get down to what you need.
And what you need is something to sell
and somebody to sell to.
And that's, I don't think that's ever gonna change.
Do you guys, I I don't, you can sell 'em ai,
but I don't think that's ever gonna change.
Think about it. It's never gonna change. You're a business.
Look, businesses can go hop on a plane and, and,
and go learn about the latest and newest gadget
and everything else, but they're spending money
when it comes back to being in the business.
They gotta have something to sell.
They gotta have a product service to sell, period.
Or you can't pay your bills.
You can't, you see what I'm saying?
Like, that's, that's common sense to me.
And I don't feel like people have common sense out there.
That's never going to change. Never.
So when you see me start to introduce those things, guys,
don't let it go in your head that, all right,
I'm just gonna focus on that.
'cause that's so much better than
building out stupid courses and engaging emails.
All that stuff is from, from 2000 a long time ago.
No, don't think that way. Don't think that way.
You still gotta do this, guys, I'll, I'll bring you mt.
Bot and all that crazy stuff. I'll bring all that stuff.
Claude code and vibe code. I'll bring it all.
I, I I'm wave the flag. Fine. It is time.
Now, I, now I think that we can teach this stuff.
I'll bring it all to you.
But do not forget everything that we built last year.
You need it. The quizzes, you need it member,
you need it Letterman, you need it gc, you need it.
You need all these things, folks. All of these things.
And you need business owners hitting your pipeline.
And you need to be sending out emails like what Jim's doing,
and you need to be connecting with them.
You need to be asking for the money
or you'll never make money.
Wow. How crazy is that?
If you don't ask for the money, you can't make the money
playing with an AI tool
or whatever, you're probably not gonna be asking
for the money, right?
So does everybody understand that now?
So we'll go, we'll go play at the shiny for a while,
but don't forget the base that we have here
and just watch me watch what I'm doing.
You don't see me, you don't see me
venturing too far from it.
You know, we spend 20% of our time
focus on the new shiny stuff to engage people
and 80% of our time taking care of our list and making sales
and reengaging and doing our calls.
'cause that's what pays the bills.
And I don't care who the influencer is
that you're following, it could be an ex-partner of mine.
It doesn't matter to me.
The fact that they're on their wall, the fact
that they're doing workshops, doing trainings tells me
that they're selling something.
And maybe they are selling ai, but they're still selling it.
They're still selling it, okay? That'll never change.
It'll never change. So stay
on track with what you guys are doing.
Keep sending out your newsletter. It's gonna get good.
It's gonna get really, really good this year.
All right guys, I gotta go close out my team. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you. Keep me posted to your success, Josh.
I'll send you your link and I'll see you guys on Friday.
Bye everybody.